what's up you guys time once again for
the movie retrospective
here's the one that won this week by a
very very significant margin
this is the 1995 film seven
yeah it's a good one yeah this is well
it's really interesting because
here's what's really interesting about
this this was
this was not david fincher's first movie
i kind of want to get into that a little
bit too but it was kind of his first one
that was critically acclaimed in case
you did not know his first movie was
actually alien three
and he hated the experience of making
that movie so much that he doesn't even
like it on his resume anymore
he basically said because i think he'd
done like music videos and stuff like
that prior
and when he made alien 3 after that came
out
he said i believe his quote was
something along the lines of i would
rather get
colon cancer than work on another movie
would i you know because of the
experience that he went through with it
luckily he did not go through with that
because uh shortly after that he ended
up making seven and then he went on to
make like
so many awesome awesome movies zodiac
he's behind mind hunter
uh you know benjamin button he did all
of his fight club he did all of these
really really great movies
so it's awesome that he um decided
after his terrible experience with alien
3 that he was actually going to continue
being a filmmaker even though he was
kind of like [ __ ] this i'm going back to
music videos like after he made that
alien 3 wasn't on him though yeah well
that's what he's saying he's like he's
just like the
he basically made him do crazy [ __ ] and
then support supporting him
well that's what he said he's like
basically it was just kind of like there
was so much interference and
he got to a point where he's like if if
you can't do what you want if it's not
like your vision then you might as well
not make it
because what's the point of it you know
what i'm saying
i mean they would give him crazy ideas
for alien three before he was even on it
yeah they're like do this the wooden
planet there's gonna be a wooden one
it's the gender blade and they're like
what there's a bunch of crazy [ __ ]
it was crazy but so the fact that this
movie
even got made it all because there was
um a lot of kind of
uh a little bit of wannabe studio
meddling with it because the guy that
wrote the script andrew kevin walker
he initially wrote the script pretty
much the way you see it
in the final movie um with the uh very
famous
bummer ending and all but what ended up
happening was when the studio was trying
to get david fincher
involved they sent him they were
supposed to send him the revised one
that had like a happier ending or
at least an ending that was more in line
with a traditional
like buddy cop or detective uh police
procedural type of movie
so they were supposed to send him that
draft but they accidentally sent him the
original draft
with the famous head in the box scene
and david fincher read it and it's like
this is fantastic
it's like you know it's it's just like
it's like a police procedural but then
it goes like in a different direction
and it's like a meditation on evil and
all this other stuff
and the studio's like the [ __ ] you
talking about and then he was like yeah
with the end with the box and they were
just like oops we sent you the wrong one
so it's like in a way it's kind of good
that that happened though because
him wanting to do the movie was kind of
contingent upon
it ending that way like in a really
bleak fashion and also
brad pitt and i think morgan freeman as
well felt so strongly that that should
be the ending
that they both threatened to walk off
the movie if
um that wasn't the end because they knew
that that's what david fincher wanted
and they thought that that was a good
end to the story so they were basically
like look we're gonna walk and not
finish the movie if you don't
go along with what the director wants so
they did eventually end up doing that
yeah the movie holds up it looks great
uh just everything about it story edit
it has a really good score it's kind of
industrial
sound like coil is it coil um i think
that uh coil did some but i think it was
a nine inch nails cover they did that
might have been over the end credits
no because i think that david bowie was
over the end right here
so maybe it wasn't because i feel like
maybe uh the opening credits
was kind of a um like a remix of closer
and i think coyle might have done that
but um yeah so the thing about this
movie is that
as i said that he did so much
interesting [ __ ] with this
and like you said this is almost like
it's you know it's a 90s movie but if
you were just watching it
i don't know if that would really come
it doesn't seem dated in any way at all
it seemed like a 90s period movie
yeah it seems like it was just shot now
basically
that's what i'm saying but it's taking
place in the 90s that's what it looks
like yeah and i think that the reason
for that um is that
they were very careful david fincher was
very careful not to put
any really obvious signposts
he's like no advertisements no nothing
like that so you can see hey
look at the you know label on that like
from the 90s or whatever he didn't want
anything like that
and he very deliberately made the city
where it's set
he didn't ever specify where that city
was
yeah it's just kind of generic it was
like a generic it was it was actually
supposed to be like a mythical cedar
like in every city almost kind of like
gotham like before batman got there it
was just supposed to be like this
cesspit
of crime and darkness and it's raining
all the time and it's just
the shitty shitty place um because he
wanted it to be more like
mythical um i think they shot it like in
and around l.a which is weird because i
always thought it was new york
because it looks like new york like it's
of all the yellow cabs and all that kind
of [ __ ] but i guess it wasn't shot there
but the fact that um you know the last
scene like where they go out of the town
like into that weird desert environment
i'm like okay well obviously that's not
new york because that doesn't look
anything like anything
but also there's that one scene too with
morgan freeman and uh
and gwyneth paltrow in the diner where
she's saying
basically that her and brad pitt's
character they moved from upstate so and
usually when you say upstate you usually
mean new york but that not necessarily
so like i said they he he wanted it to
be more mythical so he
you know deliberately didn't say
everybody calls it just like this place
or this city or something like that
they never say like where it is which
like i said
it's a it's a weird movie because it's
almost like
it's really really realistic but then
it's almost
mythic as well like at the same time and
i think that the realism of it
makes the mythic part of it work that
much better and seem that much more
approachable you know what i'm saying
because it's almost kind of like you
know like i said when david fincher
first read
the screenplay he immediately saw that
this is a meditation on
evil and also it's kind of like talking
about
how different types of people approach
evil
like and how you can continue
going on in your life when all around
you like it's just evil all around you
you know what i mean so there's like a
lot of characters there's like a lot of
discussions between
the characters about you know what it
means to be human or what it means to be
evil and
you know how you react to that you know
what i'm saying yeah
so the fact that they had the two
characters
um you know brad pitt brad pitt's
character who's called
detective mills and morgan freeman's
character who is called a detective
somerset
the fact that they had it's like a
it's a classic buddy cop police
procedural
setup you have the old grizzled
world weary detective who's just seen
some [ __ ]
and he's just too old for this [ __ ] and
he's gonna retire soon
and then you have brad pitt's character
who
apparently had a much more cushy job
like as a homicide detective like
upstate somewhere quote unquote
but then he specifically came to this
[ __ ] of a city because the crime was
so bad because he wanted to make a name
for himself but also because he thought
quote unquote that he could do some good
so he still has
some optimism to him but he's also like
much younger
and he's kind of more hot-headed um he's
not
real deep or philosophical like he
doesn't really think about the [ __ ] too
much
like all this crazy [ __ ] that happens
you know when these
murders start to occur that they figure
out are based on the seven deadly sins
he's basically like well this dude's
obviously just a lunatic
and he's very dismissive about it but
that that's kind of contrasted with
morgan freeman's character who
i'm not saying that he agrees with the
serial killer
or you know with john doe
but he understands that you don't have
to be a lunatic
to do what this dude is doing you know
what i'm saying because he's like
a normal person could do this type of
thing if they thought that they had
justification
the way i took it was that he just saw
it as kind of like a
um evidence that this dude had real
strong willpower and
faith in what he was doing and it wasn't
he wasn't a normal criminal
that's the way i saw it well that too he
did um
it's weird because they almost he was a
lunatic just that
he thought that guy really believed in
himself that's that's what i
that's i thought that's what it said
yeah although i will say that
they almost put it i don't know if i
would put it exactly like this but i've
seen some other critics put it like this
where
it's almost kind of like john doe the
serial killer and morgan freeman's
character somerset
are almost like two sides of the same
coin and it's uh you could almost say
that somerset like admires the guy
not because of what he's doing because
obviously what he's doing is horrific
but he does make a point of saying
how this dude is so methodical and how
he has a lot of
i mean because particularly the very
famous scene where they find the guy
you know the sloth murder and obviously
john doe has been you know
doing that for a year because there are
pictures of the guy like every day for a
year he's coming back and he's basically
just
you know having this guy strapped to the
bed and keeping him alive
so he will suffer longer so you know
morgan freeman is saying to
you know brad pitt's character he's like
you can't just be dismissive and say oh
he's a monster he's a lunatic or
anything like that because he's clearly
put a lot of thought into this and he's
not
you know he's not a crazy person he's
like a crazy person
the way that you're saying it was a
crazy person couldn't do something like
this
you know what i'm saying like put this
much there might have been something
where
morgan friedman's character was kind of
like symbolic of man's justice and then
this uh serial killer was like symbolic
of god's justice
or nature's justice i don't know
something like that i was watching a
thing earlier that was kind of trying to
analyze because this is it's weird
because this is like a much deeper movie
than it seems like
um so they were trying to analyze john
doe's motives
now you don't even see john doe uh
played by kevin spacey
um until almost the end of the movie and
they have there's one long scene
of all three of them in the car like
going out to where he says there's two
bodies out there which
technically ends up being true but um
just not the way people think
you know not the way they think it's
gonna go but
the stuff that he says it's almost kind
of like
so from the outset it seems like he's
sort of your religiously motivated
killer he's like you know i look around
i see
all these people sinning and
it's almost kind of like we tolerate it
you know what i mean it's like even
though
it's supposedly ascended supposedly
wrong but everybody just lets everything
slide because of apathy that's like a
big theme in this too is like people
just being apathetic about [ __ ]
so the fact that you would think that it
would be a contradiction
for him to say you know i am chosen
that's the word he uses to you know wipe
people out wipe sinners out
um you know and like i said it almost
seems like a contradiction because it's
like well
you're basically saying a murderer is a
sinner but then you're murdering them so
it's like you're not any better
but he's kind of taken that into
consideration because
spoiler alert yeah he is willing to die
he's willing to be the last
victim like i said that's why he says
we're going
out to this place there's two bodies out
there you haven't found yet
one of them's gonna be his because he
says my
crime my sin is envy
because i envy brad pitt's character
because you despite being surrounded by
evil every day still have managed to
find
some purpose in your life some meaning
in your life you you know you had a wife
that you love you had you had your dogs
you had
you still had your optimism and he's
like i envy you because i can't have
that
so basically that was uh you know that
was the statement that he was making
now the fact that brad pitt kills him
at the end um thus becoming wrath
that means that kevin spacey won he
succeeded
because that's what he was trying to do
the whole time he was trying to make a
statement with these seven murders
and that's why i don't think
that's the thing like i don't think that
john doe
planned to rope brad pitt in from the
beginning because like i said he's been
doing these
uh seven deadly sins murders for a while
i mean at least a year right because the
sloth guy has been in there for a year
so you know this takes a lot of planning
and a lot of [ __ ]
you know a lot of [ __ ]
so i think that he decided to do
what he did like and you know making
brad pitt like the
human the humanization of wrath or
whatever um
i think he decided to do that after
mills
and somerset found him i don't think he
was planning to be found that
early because they found him this is a
fun fact
how they found john doe in the movie was
by looking up his library records
right because they're like well who he's
using like all this stuff from you know
paradise lost and uh you know from
dante's divine comedy and all this other
stuff so we're like well just for shits
and giggles
let's pull the records from the library
you know the
main library and we'll see who checked
out all of these books like over the
past
now in 1995 that and this was a plot
point in the movie that was illegal
um so that's so morgan freeman was like
you know we can't like let anybody know
that how we found this dude because
i called in a couple favors but
technically you're not really supposed
to do that
however the patriot act made it legal in
2001
so it was it's funny because it was
illegal in 1995 but now it is
so now you can catch somebody like that
but yeah so i think that
the fact that he that
he admired the cops i mean he even said
that to them that they had found his
apartment when he was only like three or
four murders in
i don't think he was expecting it to
happen that early so he decided hey i'm
gonna change my plan
and then i'm gonna you know get [ __ ]
brad pitt involved in this
and kidnap his wife and put her head in
a box you know what i do
now the originally it was supposed to be
like i said
the whole head in the box thing um the
studio very much
did not want that ending because they
said it was way too bleak
and uh test audiences did not respond
well to it because they were like dude
bummer
because this is a pretty dark movie
right so when it came out i thought it
was
i thought it was good yeah that's i know
but i'm just saying like a lot of test
audiences didn't like it because they
thought
because the thing about it is that it's
set up so much like a classic
police procedural and in a classic
police procedural
you know you have conflict between the
two cops usually it's like an old
grizzled one that's all like seen it all
and then you have a young one that's all
enthusiastic it's like yeah we're gonna
catch the guy and blah blah and
we're gonna do some good in the world
and [ __ ] like that and then you have the
other character that's like man [ __ ] it
it won't even matter
like they'll just be another one
tomorrow blah blah so it's kind of like
cynicism versus optimism
so you have that going on in this
however in a classic police procedural
especially one where you're like chasing
a serial killer usually it's like a
mystery you know the cops like
you know they they follow the serial
killer they pick up all the clues from
all the crime scenes
and then in the end there's like a big
chase and there's usually like
one victim at the end who they're trying
to save you know what i mean it's like
let's not let them kill one more person
and then they usually save the person
like in the nick of time
and i think that was kind of the ending
that the studio wanted
was that um or maybe one of the
endings that the studio wanted was that
the killer was gonna
absolutely go and try and kidnap um
you know mills wife but they were going
to get there just in the nick of time
and save her like and there was going to
be a car chase and all this other kind
of stuff which like i said would have
been a very standard
police procedural thriller type of movie
but the fact that
they do all that for like the first
two-thirds of the movie where it's like
a standard police procedural
and then all of a sudden it just upends
the whole apple cart by having john doe
basically walk into the police station
and say
i surrender so it wasn't even because of
the cops
finding [ __ ] yes they did find out stuff
yes they found out who he was
and they went to his apartment but he
got away you know what i mean
so he eluded them so the fact that he
threw a monkey wrench in the works by
coming
into the thing and just giving himself
up and then basically saying
you know you two guys have to come out
i'll show you these two bodies otherwise
i'm pleading insanity and you guys won't
get justice or whatever so the fact that
it did that and it kind of took those
you know police procedural troops and
then just
[ __ ] with them i think people didn't
respond
as well to that but it's weird because
after the movie came out
i don't really think people had that
much of a problem with it because it
made
[ __ ] tons of money i think it was the
seventh highest grossing movie that year
of 1995.
i saw it in the theater when it came out
everybody was like wow that was pretty
cool i think i did too actually
you know what's funny about the movie is
that it didn't really stick with me
for very long after seeing it you know
what i mean like i saw it i appreciated
it
i remember understanding it at the time
and it was young then
i thought it was cool i liked the music
in it but then i kind of quickly forgot
about it
seeing it seeing it again kind of
brought it back it does hold up
the movie holds up um
it's just a real well-made movie yeah it
definitely does hold up and i think
that one thing too that i really like
about it
it's almost kind of like the lat it's
weird because the
the murders scenes are
meant to be really grotesque and over
the top
but i like that he doesn't show the
killer
doing them you only see the aftermath
so it almost it leaves a lot to your
imagination as grotesque as it is
and i've heard that all the poor people
that had to play
like the victims in this especially like
the guy that played gluttony like he had
to wear this big huge fat suit
and their real cockroaches like running
all over the room and they had to like
keep him from crawling up his nose and
all this other kind of [ __ ] because he
had to like lay there for ages
so the fact that they just kind of
showed the aftermath
as though you were a cop yourself and
you were just coming on the scene like
after and trying to like piece together
all the clues and stuff i think that's
kind of what distinguishes this
from just like a slasher movie or a
torture porn movie because i do think i
did see a couple of dumber critics even
from back in 1995
that kind of called this more like a
torture porn or a slasher type movie but
it absolutely is not
i mean a slasher would show the killer
killing the person that's what a slasher
is
whereas this one just showed the
aftermath
it kind of reminds me of some of the
movies that were uh made about the
zodiac killer
well david fincher also made zodiac um
which actually if i had to pick ooh it's
hard if i had to pick a favorite david
fincher maybe it would probably be
zodiac
but um this might be this this might be
my second favorite david
although the mine hunter was good too
but that was a series yeah it was a good
movie
i mean you know i don't know much more i
could say about it it was just um
what's weird is you know when i when i s
when i was
look watching this movie uh
i said jenny i said yeah i saw this when
i was in the army like my last year in
the army
and then it turned out she it was in 95
and it says no i couldn't have seen it i
was out i got out in september of 94.
and there was a lot of movies from this
era
that for some reason i get confused with
them i kind of blend them together
this one flat liners which is i don't
know why
which i'm pretty sure flat liners came
out in 1990 yeah
this one flat line well you know it's
just it's been a long time it was all
the 90s
[Laughter]
this one flat liners um what was that
other one the uh
the the one about the writer the uh
i mentioned it mentioned it the one
about the writer
yeah uh it's gone john carpenter movie
um oh uh in the mouth of matthew mouth
of madness yeah
it was in the mouth of madness was the
one that i saw in the army
and for some reason i thought it was uh
i thought it was this one
which is weird because i don't and then
because these don't really have anything
to do i know
and then there's another one that i get
confused with certain scenes
uh with all the other ones i just
mentioned end of days with arnold
schwarzenegger
okay now that is crazy yeah i don't know
what year was that
it must be something about the color
palette maybe
although you know what's weird about
this particular movie about seven
is that they what they actually did on
this movie because he wanted a very
particular look to it
they did something called a bleach
bypass which they don't really do on a
lot of
uh movies i guess like the film stock
has this kind of silvery tinge to it
so what they do is they process it to
take that silvery tinge out
but he didn't want to do that because so
he didn't so so that's what they did
they didn't like bleach all the silvery
tones out
so that's why in this movie you get like
this really weird
dark gritty like all the blacks are like
really really like rich
blacks um because he wanted that
particular look he said
he wanted this place to look like just
like a hell hole
you know what i mean just like
everything is like grimy and dirty and
gross
and it's like all claustrophobic like
they go into every
murder scene like in in pretty much
every scene it's like there's hardly any
light
you know what i mean like it's very high
contrast it's like really really dark
and then there's just like
you know bits of light coming out here
and there it's almost kind of like
you know especially like the fat guys
apartment and everything like that i
think that
the fat guys department i kind of love
that they
start out with that because it's kind of
like there's
there's a very brief scene where they
introduce uh you know
mills and somerset i love that they
don't really give them much of a
backstory
they're just kind of like you know
figure out their personalities just from
the way they act which i thought was
really uh
cool and you can get you get a really
good sense of their characters just
in very brief sketches and i think
that's really well done
but i love that after that scene where
they're kind of like arguing with each
other then they immediately go to the
scene where there's this big huge fat
guy
who you know and there's like cans of
spaghetti sauce there's a bucket of
vomit
there's roaches everywhere it's just
like the nastiest [ __ ] [ __ ] i think
when i saw this in the theater i was
like
and even though they don't even show
like in the bucket or anything but it's
like
another one i get confused with it all
gets thrown in there here was [ __ ] uh
jacob's ladder yeah that was awesome i'm
pretty sure that was also in 1990.
that that's another one that i kind of
get confused they all
they all kind of get lumped together for
me for some reason well maybe because
you saw a lot of movies during that time
period so it's all kind of like
all of a piece and there's something
about them because they kind of have
darker tones in them you know
they're not real brightly lit movies so
they kind of just feel the same to me
although when we went back and saw
flatliners i couldn't believe
what a good-looking movie that was i had
also forgotten like how the color
beautiful that movie was i i for some
reason because i saw that in the theater
too but
for some reason i think we mentioned
this when we reviewed it a while back
but i thought
i remembered all of the like really
beautiful architecture and stuff but for
some reason i thought it was just like a
gold brown like earth tone type of movie
but it wasn't it was like really
it was it was almost like a mario baba
type [ __ ] going on
which i had totally forgotten about yeah
but yeah this movie like i said
um i really like that they just show
you know this grotesque um
aftermath of the crimes and the one they
didn't even show they just showed like
the
the lust one where the prostitute
basically got [ __ ] to death by a knife
dildo
um which they just did by suggestion
and i think that that's really good
because
i mean in real life yes i know there's
serial killers that do
crazy [ __ ] like i write about them all
the time but
one like this in the movie um
in real life it would strain credulity i
mean you know what i mean there's
somebody that had this much planning
going into it this much you know like i
said the dude was like going on for like
a year like
setting all this stuff up and like
having like but that's very common with
movie serial killers which i think is
maybe why the public perceives serial
killers as being actually kind of
smarter than they are
just because you know so many movie ones
are all like devious and they have all
these plans and stuff
but i think the fact that yes you have
the unbelievability factor of a serial
killer actually
being able to pull all of this off and
it going the way that he
is planning for it to go but i think
that the movie being
so grounded in reality and
looking like real [ __ ]
um really really helps sell it you know
what i mean like you totally buy it
you totally buy because their reactions
to it are completely
legit and i i just really like and also
too
i like that he shot it like not
because i feel like a lot of stuff
nowadays and a lot of movies like that
even back in the 90s
the camera was very kinetic like they
used like a lot of handheld they use a
lot of kind of stuff like that
he didn't really do that um he used like
a lot of real still
kind of shots you know what i mean just
kind of regular because he just wanted
it to look
like just as realistic as possible so
you could kind of get away with
you know the more outlandish elements i
guess you could say just this
grotesquery of these people you know
it's somebody force-feeding a fat guy
until and then kicking him so his
[ __ ] stomach explodes
and like all of a sudden when you say it
or you know [ __ ] to death by a knife
dildo that sounds ridiculous
but when you see it in the movie you're
like yeah totally
it was cutting edge in the day oh
definitely and and i think that like you
said
artistic statement yeah and because it
has a lot of deeper meaning like i said
it's kind of um
a meditation on on evil on how
people tolerate evil on how people react
to evil how you continue living
uh you know in a world which has so much
evil in it it has a lot of that in it
and i think too like i said the way it's
shot um
you know the choices that he made really
helps it
not seem dated now i hadn't seen i saw
this in the theater and then i probably
saw it two or three times subsequently
like in the 20 uh whatever
year since it's come out 30 years i
don't even know no brad pitt was young
i can't count but yeah like other than
that if you watch it nowadays i don't
really know it might it doesn't scream
90s to me
you know what i mean it's i can watch it
and
not really think about what time period
it was made in or
you know what i mean it's just other
than like yeah there's old cars and [ __ ]
like that but it doesn't
scream a time period at me
well it's just well made so
like like you said it seems like it was
just made yesterday yeah it
seems like it was like but it seems like
a period piece
yeah you know what i mean like it's
talking about the 90s but just the way
it's filmed the
quality of it you know it looks really
good yeah i mean i think it was made to
be
timeless and to have a kind of realistic
quality but also a mythic
quality so it could take place anywhere
anytime
because and i mean and that was very
deliberate because he said you know evil
is
eternal it's always around so it's like
i wanted something that you couldn't
really place in one specific time or
play for me i could i could place it
one the guns and the uniforms well yeah
sure and then
the mute the soundtrack or the the score
the score is all very industrial 90s
industrial yeah and it's got some you
know
got a track off a [ __ ] bit off of
david bowie's outside
album so you know what i mean like that
places it in time but it's
kind of like cutting edge 90s they're
trying to
make kind of an underground movie an
underground theme for the mainstream
uh but it's still kind of shot like an
rflick it's good yeah which like i said
i think that goes a long way toward it
still being talked about
this many decades later because you know
but like i said
seven it's a classic amazing that david
fincher did this
and this was like i said other than
alien three which was
[ __ ] up and like you said it wasn't
really his fault this is like
technically his first there's also a lot
of themes in the movie that were real
being talked about a lot you know in the
90s a lot of like abortion themes and a
lot of
religion themes and secular you know
secularism you know
should the government's getting away
from religious concepts going more
towards the secularism
which that's the the villain was kind of
like
backlash against that so
culturally you could tell that it was a
lot more relevant in the 90s
but it doesn't matter you know what i
mean you just watch the movie
yeah that's what i mean it doesn't it
doesn't jump out at you right you know
what i mean
as this was made in this era or whatever
so uh but yeah if you haven't seen seven
like i said it was just
we just spoiled the ending but come on
everybody knows what that even if you
haven't seen this movie everybody knows
what's in the box what's in the box
everybody knows that it became a meme
and uh you know what i mean although
it's funny we were watching it last
night and you hadn't seen it in a long
time
yeah i forgot and then you you had
forgotten what was in the box and i'm
like oh my god you seriously forgot what
was it
goop's head is in there i wouldn't have
you know i probably when i when i first
saw it i probably didn't guess what was
in the box yeah
not until they said it and i was like oh
all right it was supposed to be a dog's
head because that was supposed to be
less upsetting than a human head i'm
like i don't really know
i think i think a dog had to be more
upsetting than a human head
i mean maybe that's just me i don't
really know
well not to him yeah but i'm just saying
that that's how they wanted to soften it
in the end they
they ended up softening it because
originally it was supposed to end with
him shooting john doe
the end credits but at least they they
added that one little
end scene where um where it seems that
uh somerset has decided not to retire
that he's actually gotten a little bit
of his optimism back
that um you know he's basically like
maybe i can still do some good i'll be
around
i remember at the time seeing this now
that now that you're talking about that
ending
i remember at the time that i saw it
back in the 90s
it was also kind of really um
i i remember thinking that it was kind
of like a continuation or
it was topping or or topping uh silence
of the lambs
because yeah i really like silence the
lamb so i remember thinking like it's
kind of like science of the lambs
a little bit like the zodiac case though
you know that's the
that's how i remembered it yeah it was
like real
it had it gritty kind of industrial edge
to it
yeah i mean i love silent the lamps too
that came out four years before this
yeah and i was trying to put myself back
in
back in the 90s you know i'm trying to
remember what it was i thought of this
movie
i did like it it does have a lot of
silence on the land yes and i kind of
i kind of forgot about it yeah
i forgot about it pretty quickly because
there was so much good stuff coming
well there's so many things that
happened 94 is like one of the was
probably one of the biggest
years for movies ever and you know what
i mean and this one just came out a year
later because 94 you had [ __ ]
you know pulp fiction you had like all
these great movies came out in 94. there
was a whole new
wave of movies started to come in which
kind of
superseded this they weren't quite as
dark you know or or you know
they weren't as so much of downers yeah
because this is kind of a downer it is a
downer
um stuff like frighteners and the craft
you know and
i think the craft came out after this
but yeah i appreciate it yeah that might
have been 96.
yeah i remember i remembered that i
really liked that movie when it came out
of course i had it had cute girls in it
yeah and that was just kind of fun
it was just a fun i mean it was a horror
movie but it was still it was fun
but definitely so like i said david
fincher also directed zodiac which is
probably
my favorite movie of his if i had to
pick one um we'll probably end up
reviewing that one of these days because
i [ __ ] love that movie you know what
else is another one that kind of came
out after this that was
kind i i remembered it being kind like
this was what was it called eight
millimeter
where the guy was trying to track down
snowflakes
i thought that was much later unless i
was like i don't remember
it was like 97 i don't remember yeah
when that one came out i think it was
like 97 i don't even remember if i saw
that
like i remember seeing posters and stuff
but i don't know if i remember being
kind of like something kind of like this
yeah yeah well you know it was the 90s
it was the 90s it was so long ago i
don't even [ __ ] remember the [ __ ]
90s that was that
matrix came out i was in my 20s and so
you know all right so yeah definitely um
we actually watched i think this used to
be on netflix because
that's why i put on the list because i
could have sworn that it was on netflix
but when i looked
for it to watch it for the thing it
wasn't on there anymore so we ended up
having to go on amazon prime and rent it
for 1.99
so we could review it but yeah so uh
what's in the box i don't know 7 david
fincher
watch it we'll see you next time bye